well we start off in armenia where
months of political tensions have
reached
boiling point sparking concerns of
violence well today there were mass
rallies
in armenia's capital yerevan with both
opponents
and supporters of embattled prime
minister nicole parshion
taking to the streets while mr pashnyan
has himself
led thousands of his supporters through
the streets denouncing what he called an
attempted military coup
after armenia's armed forces demanded
his resignation
passion has faced months of protests
since
armenia's defeat by azerbaijan and the
conflict over nagorno-karabakh
last year let's get an update now from
our correspondent emily sherwin she is
monitoring the situation
from moscow emily what can you tell us
about the situation right now in armenia
well today saw two parallel rallies
in the center of yerevan in the armenian
capital
with opponents of nicole pachinyan
calling for him to resign
those opponents today were joined by the
military
and also thousands of supporters of
nicole pashanyan also gathered
in the center of yerevan now pashinyan
has now called on all sides
to go home to leave the streets
and to instead hold talks the opposition
uh however is holding fast they have
said that they will
only talk about uh pashinyan's
resignation
and it seems that they're setting up
tents in the center
of the city uh they say they're prepared
to stay all night
until pashinyan resigns this is part of
an ongoing political crisis as you say
which erupted
after the war in nagorno-karabakh
after all armenia was forced to sign
a cease-fire which many see as
a humiliation for the country it had to
give up
several territories within
nagorno-karabakh which is an ethnically
armenian majority enclave
inside azerbaijan and which has always
been recognized
by the international community as being
part of azerbaijan but for
many armenians that cease-fire was
certainly a defeat and one that is
represented by
pashinyan himself emily how much popular
support
is there for the prime minister
well when i was there a few months ago
people were already calling for
pashinyan's resignation after that
ceasefire agreement
many people really see it as a
humiliation they were saying to me
he sold off part of armenia part of our
territory
so it's really a huge national uh defeat
however today uh thousands of people
heeded uh pashanyan's calls to take to
the streets thousands of people
gathered after he called on them on
facebook
and it does seem that he has more
support
um a few months later now
let's talk about the army is the army
prepared to resort
to more violence or violence i should
say
and forcibly remove the prime minister
well it's certainly unusual in armenia
for the army to
call on the prime minister to resign to
get involved in politics
i think it's unlikely that there will be
force from the side of the army
the ministry of defense has also called
for calm and
for the army not to meddle in politics
it does seem likely however that the
pressure will continue
on nicole pacinian to resign in this
ongoing
political crisis emily sherwin reporting
on the situation in armenia thank you
very
much